und dass die inzwischen euro
rot ist die chronik einer jugend wie es
noch keine gab
über zwölf jahre hat regisseur richard
linklater immer wieder an seinem film
gedreht
im mittelpunkt steht mason dargestellt
von allen coltrane umzüge prägen sein
junges leben die eltern gespielt von
porsche erkennt und ethan hawke leben
getrennt
zwischen den bildern vergeht erst fast
unmerklich dann immer unausweichlicher
die kindheit das leben die zeit davon
handelt der eine verbeugung vor trifft
yuan wan elf filmen ist das kino ist
eine skulptur aus zeit hat der russische
filmemacher andrej tarkowski ein vorbild
linklaters gesagt das lässt sich nicht
abstrakt erklären doch man kann es
erfahren beispielsweise in beirut
linklaters großen amerikanischen kino
das auf europäischer tradition fuß